[Música]
a
escala en parís aida palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 el sahel en áfrica lleva años siendo
el escenario de una gran violencia que
afecta a varios países allí se
concentran grupos armados y hadise estás
pero también criminales que trafican con
droga que en parte viene de
latinoamérica hoy hace escala en parís
alguien que conoce muy bien esta zona
que la ha investigado durante años se
trata de la politóloga y periodista
española beatriz mesa beatriz muchísimas
gracias bienvenida gracias a en la
colonización beatriz es corresponsable
en rabat en marruecos para varios medios
de comunicación entre ellos esta casa
radio francia internacional y también es
investigadora y profesora en la
universidad gastón de ausiàs de san luís
en senegal y en la universidad
internacional de rabat y acaba de
publicar un libro interesantísimo en
francés ley q para que osael los grupos
armados en el sahel conflictos y
economía criminal en el norte de mali en
la editorial
y es el fruto de más de una década
consagrada a investigar esta compleja
zona del mundo y el enfoque de este
libro beatriz va más allá de reducir esa
violencia
a grupos yihadistas como aqmi o el
estado islámico
en esa zona oa movimientos
independentistas como el movimiento
nacional para la liberación de las
abarcas y denominan a la zona
septentrional de malí usted sostiene que
hay grupos criminales quienes son si
efectivamente bueno yo lo que vengo a
decir una de mis principales tesis en
este libro es que detrás de esos grupos
que se asientan sobre la ideología del
yihad o que se asientan también son la
ideología secesionista independentista
hay toda una configuración de actores
que trabajan codiciosamente porque lo
que están buscando sobre todo es el
control territorial el control de un
espacio porque es un espacio floreciente
en términos económicos ya que por ese
espacio transita todo tipo de ilícitos y
delitos cuando hablamos de ilícitos nos
referimos concretamente a drogas
vehículos que trafican con cocaína pero
también vehículos que trafican con
personas con armas y luego una industria
que es una de las más importantes que es
la que realmente ha transformado el
paradigma del sahel y esa industria es
la que hace ilusión a los secuestros
hace años de occidentales hoy se ha
vulgarizado si me lo permites el
secuestro no son harto gres híbridos hay
que trabajar entre violencia política y
crimen organizado y qué relación tienen
con esos grupos
yihadistas se solapan son los mismos
trabajan unos para los otros
está bien colocada la pregunta porque
efectivamente hay amalgamas hay
solapamientos de ahí la dificultad de
discernir quién es puramente
ortodoxamente terrorista yihadista y
quién es solamente que pertenece a la
organización de crimen organizado pues
no es fácil y no deberíamos de hacer esa
diferencia porque precisamente son
grupos híbridos o actores híbridos aquel
que
boston o un arma un kalashnikov de
acuerdo con objetivos de carácter
político como podría ser un objetivo de
carácter independentista que quiere
instalar el estado de las aguas al mismo
tiempo se está beneficiando de estos
tráficos en los que estoy hablando hasta
el punto de que esa economía criminal es
la que se encuentra o es la que se sitúa
en la fuente de la inestabilidad en el
caso de malí y que se ha propagado en
toda la región del sahel por eso es tan
complejo una vez más de corte que al
actor lo que usted quiere también
subrayar es que muchas veces esos grupos
criminales se ponen una etiqueta
política para legitimarse en la zona no
eso es fundamental aida es decir una
organización criminal
una organización política necesita
federar a ciudadanos federal a
ciudadanos para legitimarse popularmente
y poder actuar y poder actuar tú tienes
que conducir a jóvenes hacia un objetivo
político le tienes que convencer con
ideas porque son las ideas también en un
momento determinado las que pueden hacer
que un pase de una situación digamos
pacífica a una situación de violencia a
convencerle pues una vez más a llevar a
recurrir al arma y a sembrar terror
entonces tú necesitas las ideologías
para federar pero realmente tú como
élite de la organización te como de la
ideología o te conmueve el control
territorial a través de una vez más de
la entidad porque no podemos entender el
control de un espacio sin conocer las
identidades que dan lugar a ese espacio
es decir cuando hablamos del norte de
mali nos estamos refiriendo a grupos
híbridos de yihadismo o de secesionismo
de que me organizado pero que se
asientan sobre una opción fundamental
tribal la tribu y fuga es la tribu y
mirada de la tribu árabe punta esto es
fundamental porque si no no se entiende
el norte de mali sino no se entiende el
sahel la identidad tribal comunitaria es
fundamental para conocer mejor la
configuración de los grupos armados
porque cada grupo está luchando por el
control de un espacio determinado
defiende una cuestión identitaria junto
como digo con ese control económico
versus territorio versus política
y en el control económico
lo hablábamos antes bueno pues se
trafica con personas con la inmigración
clandestina
tráfico de armas secuestros y también
tráfico de drogas explicamos qué es la
autopista a10 bueno en la autopista
número 10 se hace alusión al paralelo 10
el paralelo que transita entre américa
latina y la cornisa atlántica del áfrica
del oeste por ese paralelo que se
traduciría en la vía marítima por donde
han transitado durante el siglo 20 y
actualmente barcos que transportan
cocaína de donde procede esa cocaína de
países como colombia que es un productor
de cocaína de planta de cocaína y que
siempre pues había comercializado con
los eeuu a través de una plataforma que
era méxico como lugar de tránsito en el
momento en que se empieza a cerrar esa
frontera porque hay un mayor control por
parte de las autoridades se buscan otras
fronteras de tránsito cuál es esa
frontera el sahel desde donde desde
senegal desde gambia desde guinea bissau
en esas zonas desembarca como digo las
drogas por esa vía marítima y que entran
en la zona del sahel pero porque ayuda
es particularmente mal importante decir
mal y hasta el momento no es un
productor de cocaína como lo es colombia
malí no es por el momento el norte de
mali lo que se conoce como más agua
tampoco es un productor de recursos
naturales de momento que posee uranio
posee gas pero en que se convierte por
eso la convierte en algo peligroso por
es una zona de tránsito
sin ser necesariamente un productor de
se convierte en una zona de tránsito
fundamental de esos recursos ilícitos y
por eso se transforma la organización
social de los actores locales y se
transforma toda la región porque se
convierte en ese lugar de tránsito de
los ilícitos que proceden de américa
latina en el libro habla de un dato el
35 por ciento de la cocaína producida en
latinoamérica
va a áfrica de la oeste para luego ser
transportada
a europa incluso pistas de aterrizaje de
aviones no sólo se transporta en barcos
y también en el sahel hay pistas de
aterrizaje exclusivamente para esos
aviones si efectivamente en el norte de
mali que podríamos decir que es una zona
constituida por lugares grises porque no
habría una representación estatal porque
esto está en manos de los actores no
estatales vamos a decir grupos armados
ellos han tenido la capacidad durante
todos estos últimos años de abrir pistas
de aterrizaje en pleno ex ángel eso
quiere decir que efectivamente más allá
de la vía marítima existe una vía aérea
que ha permitido el desembarco de
aviones procedentes de américa latina'
de hecho en su momento en 2009 fue
noticia porque se llegó a identificar un
boing que no pudo despegar con lo cual
ese fue el dato visual la única imagen
que teníamos de que efectivamente
también se utilizaba la vía aérea
pero hay que decir que eso se ha ido
desarrollando durante todos estos años y
que sigue habiendo zonas aeroportuarias
en donde desembarcan estos aviones con
grandes volúmenes
los secuestros son moneda corriente en
esa zona en el libro afirma que se pagan
unos dos millones de euros por
secuestrado es una industria muy muy muy
importante para el crimen organizado ahí
tenemos el caso de la religiosa
colombiana de gloria cecilia narváez que
fue secuestrada por un grupo afiliado al
qaeda en 2017 en mali y fue liberada a
finales del 2021 usted evoca este
secuestro y otros muchos en el libro
quien la secuestró y por qué si vamos a
ver
empieza por el porqué y esto es
fundamental porque es lo que realmente
defiende mi tesis los secuestros de
occidentales de europeos
estos secuestros no han respondido a
cuestiones ideológicas del infiel del
cáncer como se ha venido explicando para
el caso por ejemplo de nuestra religiosa
gloria que sigamos a la mujer cristiana
pues se captura por este objetivo no
estos secuestros que empezaron sobre
todo en 2003 y que han ido in crescendo
a partir de 2007 89 ha respondido
siempre a la codicia de estos grupos
armados qué encontraron un nicho de
actuación y sobre todo un nicho para
adquirir altos beneficios que
beneficiado actuales no estatales pero
también actores estatales incluidos los
propios jefes de estado de acuerdo
entonces
estos supuestos como explicaba que
suponen un actor internacional un
notario un rehén occidental supone en su
momento eran quinientos mil euros pero
después se ha ido cotizando porque ha
ido funcionando porque porque un proceso
de liberación de un rehén significaba la
implicación de actores estatales como
puede ser francia colombia españa reino
unido y que ponía mucho de no sobre la
mesa para poner en libertad ese rehén
cuando estos actores no estatales que
forman parte del norte de mali que
tienen que ver con esas identidades a
las que me refería vieron que había un
gran negocio floreciente alrededor de
esos secuestros pues aquello empezó a
proliferar se y empezó a crecer y por
eso hemos visto en los últimos diez años
pues una sucesión de rehenes de
secuestros que responden como digo a la
codicia la ambición económica
a gloria la secuestrado por ejemplo el
grupo de ánsar de liderado por
ilegalidad galli es un independentista
de la llamada rebelión de los años 90
que supuestamente ha transitado hacia
grupos de yihadismo se les llama un
actor radical pero a mi juicio no es un
radical sino que simplemente utiliza el
yihad una vez más para legitimarse
alcanzar efectivamente pues mayores a
mayor apoyo pero más allá del yihad lo
que es importante en el que es único gas
y fue gas es la principal facción
tuareg que ha ganado pues mucha
legitimidad sobre todo la zona de
equidad de donde viene y ya calidad
galli se extingue la al qaeda en el
magreb islámico y sobre todo empieza
como digo en estos tráficos de ilícitos
y concretamente la industria él era un
negociador un mediador entre amadú
tumani turé el presidente de la
república en su momento de malí y los
actores armados del norte y esa
mediación servía para que los beneficios
que procedían de los secuestros fueran
repartidos con el estará nuevamente
entre el estado los grupos no estatales
grupos armados no estatales entonces ha
funcionado también el secuestro de los
catalanes cooperantes en 2009 que fueron
secuestrados en mauritania pero hemos
tenido italianos más españoles
australianos y en el caso de la
colombiana la colombiana han sido años
largos de negociación porque que se
estaba esperando se le podía ver
afortunadamente una ocurrido pero si
realmente hubiera sido un objetivo
puramente político podría haber sido
asesinada y no ha sido el caso
bueno beatriz mesa ya no nos queda más
tiempo muchísimas gracias y le deseamos
muchísimo éxito con este libro tan
interesante los grupos armados del sahel
y a ver si pronto lo podemos ver en
español muchas gracias y muchas gracias
a todos ustedes por habernos acompañado
ya saben que nos pueden seguir por
internet también en la rdc y mundo.com y
en france24 punto com hasta pronto
amigos
y
[Música]